[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le 7-8 lipdo
nous sommes le vendredi 10 juillet et
voici le sommaire de cette édition la
ministre délégué à l'industrie alias
panière une hache est venu en visite
dans le sud du département
un déplacement consacré à la reconquête
industrielle reportage à venir dans ce
numéro
la députée yvelinoise nadia et a créé la
surprise en étant nommé ministre délégué
à la ville dans le nouveau gouvernement
de jean castex
une nomination qui entraîne des
élections législative partielle dans la
12e circonscription
nous analyserons cela avec stéphane
minson doyen honoraire à l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
les nouveaux maires élus installé le
siaap d'achères qui renforce sa sécurité
et les bacheliers 2020 heureux de
remporter le diplôme dans ce contexte si
particulier
nous ferons le tour de l'actualité de la
semaine dans le département
on débute avec le déplacement ce
vendredi 10 juillet de la ministre
délégué à l'industrie agnès pannier rue
nash est invité par la députée aurore
bergé elles ont visité l'entreprise daco
bello à ablis cette entreprise de taille
intermédiaire e t il emploie 200
personnes et a reçu des aides de l'état
aux périodes du coc vide
reportage de man varaldo hématies de
dominer la ministre délégué à
l'industrie agnès pannier rue nager
s'est rendu à l'entreprise daco bello à
ablis sur la circonscription de la
députée aurore bergé également présente
avec le pdg elles ont pu découvrir les
étapes de fabrication des produits dako
bello beaucoup de machines mais qui ne
fonctionne pas tout seul et créer des
emplois
elles ont découvert tous les processus
de cette entreprise familiale de taille
intermédiaire spécialisé depuis près de
50 ans dans l'importation et le
conditionnement de fruits secs sécher et
de graines du monde entier outre les
dégustations l'objet de cette visite la
reconquête industrielle sur un cas très
concret on voit tout ce que peut
apporter l'industrie ça sera pour nous
un enjeu majeur
on va pas se mentir on est dans une
crise mondiale
on entend ici et là des chiffres
inquiétants de suppressions d'emplois
mais on voit aussi que l'industrie peut
créer de l'emploi qu'il ya des belles
histoires là c'est une histoire de
reprise d'un cycle était en difficulté
reprise où tous les salariés ont été
repris et reprise qui est finalement
conduit à continuer à recruter
vous parliez de 200 emplois
supplémentaires prochainement recruter
voilà comment on peut avec des sites
industriels main dans la main avec les
industriels permettre de reconstruire
notre économie
durand lakovic 19 très peu de chômage
partiel pour cette entreprise 15
personnes seulement et des produits
alimentaires plébiscitée pendant la
période du confinement
le message qui doit passer c'est un
message de de la réalité du nom d'une
entreprise pme ou eti implantées sur le
territoire avec plus de 200 salariés et
qui évidemment les problématiques qui
d'une entreprise pendant la crise post
crise on a pu montrer tout à l'heure
lors de la visite surligne les les
premiers prototypes de papier qui
remplace le plastique d'emballage papier
qui remplace le plastique cdd moment
très important dans l'histoire de
l'entreprise
le chiffre d'affaires de l'entreprise
est de 80 millions d'euros dako bello se
tournent à présent vers lee commerce
[Musique]
une actualité politique mouvementée
cette semaine dans les yvelines pour la
commenté stéphane mensonge est avec nous
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes doyen
honoraire à la faculté de droit et de
sciences politiques à lui vécu et bien
sûr les téléspecteurs les
téléspectateurs de télé 78,2 vous
connaissent bien
en début de semaine on apprenait les
noms des nouveaux ministres alors côté
evelyne certains noms circulent et de
potentiel ministre en entendez parler de
la députée aurore bergé ou du maire de
poissy karl olive et c'est finalement la
député de la 11e circonscription nadia
et qui a créé la surprise
est ce que vous vous y attendiez non je
sache je vous avoue que je n'étais pas
dans le dans le secret des dieux ni du
côté de l'élysée ni du côté de matignon
je je je suis si on m'avait demandé de
parier si vous voulez j'aurais plutôt
parié sur aurore bergé alors qu'ils qui
aurait peut-être pu être éventuellement
nommé au ministère de la culture hors
garde du rapport assez substantielles
qu'elle a rendus au sujet de de ce
domaine il ya quelques temps quelques
mois politiquement karl olive était
était peut-être pas mal placé mais
j'avoue que nadia jeunes ni je n'y
pensais pas alors mardi avait lieu dans
la soirée la passation de pouvoir nadia
est officiellement devenu ministre
délégué en charge de la ville elle
succède à julien de normandie qui a été
nommé ministre de l'agriculture
retour sur cette soirée au ministère de
la cohésion des territoires et des
relations territoriales avec nicolas
landry et aurélie ronces je te souhaite
la bienvenue au ministère de la cohésion
des territoires et des relations avec
les collectivités territoriales
nadia est accueilli par la ministre
jacqueline gourault pour sa prise de
fonction auprès d'elle yvelinoise
devient ministre délégué en charge de la
ville alors en place julien de normandie
qui rejoint le ministère de
l'agriculture
l'ex député de la 11e circonscription
des yvelines va s'occuper des zones
urbaines fortement impacté par la crise
sanitaire et les deux priorités
aujourd'hui sont évidemment l'emploi
parce qu'il faut que l'emploi que la
relance économique arrive dans ces
quartiers aussi et l'éducation parce que
cette période de confinement a eu un
effet très très grave dans la poursuite
scolaire des enfants
la politique de la ville sera au coeur
de son action une politique globale pour
lutter contre les inégalités sociales
dans les quartiers prioritaires avec
plusieurs dimensions culturelle sociale
économique ou encore éducative un sujet
de préoccupation dans plusieurs communes
de son ancienne circonscription
cette circonscription qui en fait en
réalité je lui dis tout le temps une
mini france parce que on part des
problématiques qui peuvent être des
problématiques rurales quand on est sur
la vallée de chevreuse avec la ville du
mesnil-saint-denis comme des
problématiques urbaines importantes
comme la ville de trappes d'action sera
orientée particulièrement sur les
quartiers politique de la ville mais
tous les territoires fragiles et surtout
surtout je le disais tout à l'heure
cette réconciliation entre le rural et
la ville
conséquence directe de sa nomination une
élection législative partielle va être
organisée dans les trois prochains mois
dans la 11e circonscription des yvelines
alors je vous parle je ne suis pas
candidate aux législatives
ça peut évoluer dans les jours à venir
je me donne le temps de la réflexion il
est très clair que nous aurons un
candidat ou une candidate
la république en marge de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines pour rappel
lors du second tour des élections
législatives de 2010 est nadia et
l'avait emporté avec 52 points 96 %
devant le candidat les républicains jean
michel fourgous alors la délégation à la
ville pourquoi ça lui correspond
bah écoutez elle je trouve qu'elle
n'explique pas mal c'est vrai que ça sa
circonscription
alors qui est elle le dit d'ailleurs qui
est un si vous voulez un mix un
intermédiaire entre un aspect un peu
rural c'est à dire amant un morceau de
la vallée de chevreuse et puis un côté
urbain mais urbain très axé politique de
la ville avec trapel en cours ça
cette circonscription elle pourrait si
vous voulez sociologiquement résumer un
peu à elle seule ce que
ce que doit être ou ce que pourrait être
ou ce qu'est la politique de la ville
qui est conduite en france
disons depuis une vingtaine d'années un
depuis le début dès la fin des années 90
le début des années 2000 et puis par
ailleurs au parlement on sait qu'elle a
en sa qualité de député qu'elle a déjà
travaillé sur ces sur ces sujets oui a
été vice président du groupe d'études
ville et banlieue
alors c'est pas la première et des
noises à accéder à une haute fonction de
l'état on pense à valérie pécresse qui
était ministre sous nicolas sarkozy
bien sûr gérard larcher actuel président
du sénat mme les ivèmes est ce que c'est
un peu un vivier de politiques amenés à
aller vers ces postes là non enfin je je
je je voulais y a pas il n'y a pas de
viviez sont ce sont vraiment les
circonstances qui font les circonstances
politiques essentiellement qui font que
bien dans le gouvernement actuel je
lisais une infographie dans un grand
quotidien du soir l'autre jour il ya je
crois que plus de la moitié des membres
du gouvernement qui sont issus l'île de
france avec une représentation aussi
assez importante de certaines parties de
la province enfin des régions françaises
mais tout cela je pense qu'il faut il
voir à chaque fois si vous voulez une
une conséquence des circonstances du
moment mais rien de plus en tout cas
alors autre conséquence de cette
nomination de nadia et la tenue
prochaine d'élections législatives
partielles dans la 11e circonscription
circonscription nadia et a préféré
démissionner de ses fonctions de
parlementaire dès qu'elle a appris sa
nomination son supplément son suppléant
nous savoir vous saurez dû siéger à sa
place mais il est sous le coup de
procédures judiciaires
explications de nicolas landry une
élection législative partielle dans la
12e circonscription des yvelines la
conséquence directe de la nomination de
nadia ministre délégué chargé de la
ville pour rejoindre le gouvernement
elle a décidé de démissionner de son
mandat à l'assemblée nationale
objectif éviter que son suppléant moussa
waroux ce lui succède au parlement en
août 2019 il a été mise en examen dans
le cadre d'une affaire de trafic de
stupéfiants
sur son compte twitter le principal
intéressé assure que la démission a été
prise d'un commun accord avec nadia et
dans un délai de trois mois les haies
hector de la 11e circonscription vont
être appelés aux urnes pour élire leurs
députés
conseiller municipal d'opposition de
trappes othman nas roues a été le
premier à annoncer sa candidature sur
les réseaux sociaux
naturellement cette élection législative
partielle elle se fait dans la suite du
combat que je mets la trappe qui l'a
plus grandie de la circonscription il y
en ad'autres naturellement et pour
toutes celles et cette vie de la
circonscription moi je souhaite
représenter dignement les habitants de
la circonscription l'assemblée nationale
ont porté d'abord je lui dis il ya un
combat pour les valeurs de la république
je me suis toujours positionné comme un
candidat de la droite et du centre est
donc naturellement je suis ouvert mais
je suis un élu aussi et de la droite
républicaine
je ne vais jamais renier et ce sont
aujourd'hui c'est d'ailleurs là que je
souhaite porter
de son côté le nouveau maire de trappes
à lire ab souhaite se consacrer à sa
commune en revanche il a son idée pour
représenter la gauche lors de ce
prochain scrutin
moi personnellement je vous le dis je ne
le cache pas je souhaite que benoît
hamon reviennent dans le jeu politique
je souhaite qu'il soit pourquoi pas le
député de la 11e circonscription
malheureusement ça ne dépend pas que de
moi mais je cherche je tâcherai de le
convaincre et j'espère que les
prochaines semaines les prochains mois
nous donneront l'occasion de re voir
benoît hamon en première ligne et je
souhaite canadiens viennent remettre son
titre en jeu
si elle gagne les élections législatives
qui aura lieu d'ici trois mois elle
pourra comme ministre à prendre ses
responsabilités et son suppléant ira
siéger à l'assemblée nationale pour le
moment la république en marche n'a pas
pris de décision concernant cette
élection la réflexion est en cours
les sont pour l'instant les candidats
qui vont se manifester
je ne sais pas encore les candidats qui
vont se positionner tout à l'heure j'ai
eus par sms de quelqu'un que je connais
qui est marcheurs de la première heure
qui souhaitent avoir un échange avec moi
parce qu'il souhaite se positionner pour
rappel lors du second tour des élections
législatives de 2010 est dans la 11e
circonscription
nadia l avait emporté avec 52 96% des
suffrages devant le candidat les
républicains jean michel fourgous alors
l' annonce de la candidature d'autres
manoeuvres ou qui dans un premier temps
n'a pas plu au président de la
fédération les républicains des yvelines
dans un communiqué pierre bédier juge
cette annonce solitaire et précipité
sachant que le maire de bois d'arcy
philippe benassaya était pressenti il a
même confié être candidat
la candidature chez nos confrères de
cette ut actus.fr un comité
départemental de fait se tenir jeudi
soir pour désigner un candidat
il n'a finalement pas eu lieu et des
négociations sont en cours pour trouver
une candidature commune qui fera
consensus au sein des républicains des
yvelines de son côté nadia et se donne
du temps et de la réflexion et assure
qu'il y aura une candidature
lrm dans la 11e circonscription stéphane
lancement les républicains semblent
tiraillés entre deux candidatures qui
donne batna through de philippe
benassaya les représenterait le mieux
selon vous on peut aussi penser qu'il ya
d'un côté la chapelle valérie pécresse
et la chapelle sert bédié dans les
yvelines voilà là vous me posez une
question qui n'a pour laquelle je n'ai
évidemment pas de réponse
vous avez l'alchimie internes aux
différents partis politiques et plus
encore et vous avez raison de le
souligner lorsque comme c'est très
fréquent ces partis politiques sont
traversés par des courants par des
chapelles par des espèces de de souilhe
dessous parti ou de courants qui sont
autant idéologique quelques nuances
idéologiques parfois mais enfin parfois
il y en a même pas ce sont parfois des
des courants qui sont liées à une
personnalité au regard de 2,2
l'influencent politique de cette
personnalité ou de ou parfois aussi de
son delà de la profondeur de son
implantation locale
là moi je je si vous voulez je ma boule
de cristal là ne me dit rien je suis
bien incapable de vous dire qui
représentera l'est républicain à cette
élection législative ce dont je peux me
réjouir en qualité de citoyen c'est de
voir que finalement les candidats ne
manquent pas et que ça c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt bon signe ce qui a plutôt
tendance à manquer de nos jours ce sont
les électeurs beaucoup plus que les
candidats alors section du sia ti vont
avoir un réel enjeu la 11e
circonscription avait créé la surprise
en 2017 avec l'élection de nadia et la
droite comme la gauche pourrait
peut-être prendre sa revanche un retour
de benoît hamon et espérer pareil
ab mais il faut quand même voir que
depuis l'instauration du quinquennat du
quinquennat présidentiel en lieu et
place du septennat
donc depuis cette réforme du quinquennat
qui n'a pas que des aspects positifs
il ya au moins une incidence et c'est la
conséquence qui d'ailleurs avait été
voulue avait été souhaitée c'est que les
élections législatives qui se déroulent
un mois et demi à deux mois après
l'élection présidentielle
ces élections législatives sont en
quelque sorte entraîné bénéficie de
l'effet d'entraînement politique
conférée par l'élection présidentielle
donc la vague la république en marche de
juin 2010 est consécutive à l'élection
la présidence de la république d'un
manuel macron et bien elle
elle était évidemment totalement lié
totalement concomitante avec l'élection
présidentielle il yad'autres d'autres
exemples qui pourrait être trouvé dans
l'histoire institutionnelle mais en tout
cas le quinquennat il a pour effet de
lui lié de manière très étroite
ces deux élections l'élection
présidentielle est en quelque sorte la
locomotive politique pour les élections
l'egypte pour les élections législatives
là est bien quand on est dans une
configuration politique complètement
différente avec une fin de mandat un
début de fin de mandat pour le président
de la république avec des questions de
popularité qui peuvent se poser à
l'égard de l'équipe de l'équipe
gouvernementale et présidentielle en
place donc il y aura t'il une revanche
côté gauche où côté droit je ne peux
vous le dire mais ce que je peux vous
dire c'est qu'en tout cas le candidat ou
la candidate la république en marche va
partir avec un handicap à celle où on
arrive à la fin de cet entretien merci
stéphane minson d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
nous voulons prier avec plaisir quant à
nous on passe au reste de l'actualité de
la semaine
[Musique]
et nous l'avons appris juste après
l'enregistrement de cet entretien othman
nas roues s'est vu confier la première
vice-présidence à la région ile de
france en charge des affaires
internationales et européennes
il précise dans un communiqué qu'il
quitte donc son mandat de vice-président
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines mais qu'ils restent candidats
pour les législatives de la 11e
circonscription lundi si nous
connaissions les noms des nouveaux
maires de saint quentin en yvelines dont
les listes avait remporté le second tour
des élections municipales à trappes
c'est à lire ab qui prend la suite du
maire sortant guy malandain un conseil
d'installation sous tension où le maire
sortant à quitter la salle à l'élection
de son successeur
du côté de la verrière le passage à
droite et officialisé nicolas dainville
a été élu samedi 4 juillet
la maire sortante neelie du siège
désormais dans l'opposition avec cinq
autres membres de sa liste à villepreux
jean baptiste à monique succède à
stéphane mirambeau âgé de 28 ans
l'ancien élu de la majorité met fin à
douze années de mandat du maire sortant
si les petits guen prend l'écharpé de
maire aux clayes-sous-bois et succède à
la maire sortante véronique côté millard
qui n'avait pas souhaité se représenter
et avait soutenu sa candidature à
guyancourt françois morton conserve son
siège et son opposant du premier tour
qui avait fusionné sa liste au second
devient adjoint en charge de la
démocratie permanente à plaisir pas de
changement joséphine coleman ce berger
et est même la seule à se porter
candidates lors du conseil
d'installation
elle démarre son troisième mandat enfin
à voisins le bretonneux alexandra
rosetti est réélu maire sa liste était
arrivée en tête avec 54 10% des voix
c'était le 3 juillet 2019 les usines de
traitement des eaux usées du siaap à
achères connaissez un incendie
un an plus tard lundi 6 juillet 2020 la
préfecture des yvelines organisé une
réunion avec les différentes parties
prenantes
objectif faire un point d'étape sur
l'évolution de la situation et le suivi
de cet incident reportage de nicolas
landry
voici les premières images du futur
bâtiment de l'usiné de traitement des
eaux usées du siaap à achères une
reconstruction suite à l' incendie du 3
juillet 2019
une nouvelle organisation autour de deux
bâtiments avec un site réservé au
stockage de chlorure ferrique à
l'intérieur du bâtiment de la classe
population ce qui a surtout brûlé c'est
le stockage de chlorure ferrique donc ce
stockage là on va le reconstruire à côté
et du coup avec des mesures en termes de
sécurité incendie qui sont beaucoup plus
draconiennes que celles dont on
disposait dans l'ancien bâtiment
depuis un an le bâtiment touché par
l'incendié a été nettoyé les travaux de
reconstruction devraient être lancés en
2021 pour une livraison en 2022
en attendant le siaap travaille sur une
nouvelle organisation
objectif renforcer la sécurité
aujourd'hui on est encore dans une
culture où c'est la production donc le
traitement des eaux qui est la priorité
est la sécurité n'est pas encore une
priorité suffisamment importante pour
l'ensemble de nos agents et notamment
pour nos encadrants donc c'est ce
travail là qu'on va mener dans les deux
trois ans qui viennent
les résultats d'un audit et d'une
expertise sur l'origine de cet incendie
ont été présentés lors d'une réunion
d'information auprès des parties
prenantes à la sous-préfecture de
saint-germain-en-laye
la cause la plus probable du départ de
feu serait un défaut d'isolement de
câbles électriques
l'incendié étant d'origine électrique il
est susceptible de se reproduire et
qu'il faut donc d'une part diminuer ce
risque et surtout en limiter les
conséquences pour rassurer les élus
locaux et la population les services de
l'état poursuivent la communication sur
ce dossier
des exercices de sécurité devrait être
organisé en novembre au niveau des
opérations de commandement puis avec les
maires et la population en avril 2021
mardi c'était le jour j pour les plus de
soixante et onze mille candidats du bac
2020 dans l'académie de versailles un
bac un peu particulier cette année
puisque les élèves ont été notées en
contrôle continu en raison de la crise
sanitaire les résultats n'étaient pas
affichés devant les établissements les
candidats étaient malgré tout invités à
venir récupérer leur relevé de notes
réactions recueillies à montigny le
bretonneux avec or il est rose et jules
cachan
voilà donc on a le bec moi je m'en sors
assez bien la dame on sait très bien et
18 de moyenne on peut tous l'applaudir
marveaux je savais que j'allais avoir
mon bac mais je savais pas quelle
mention je pensais que j'allais avoir la
mention bien mais du coup j'ai été
surpris suis très bien où je suis
contente a admis mention très bien en
bike assez spécial pas qu'ils
demandaient pas trop d'effets enfin tout
ce qu'ils demandaient de l'effort sur
l'annexé terme et de l'effort sur une
courte période et des serpents les
week-ends de l'édition x factor
moi j'ai mon bac sans mention j'étais
pas loin de la mention mais voilà avec
10 80 je suis plutôt content quand même
de la voir avec le co vide
c'est vrai qu'on appréhendait beaucoup
comment allaient être les bulletins
comment ça allait se passer donc
on hésitait certains coûté 3 de notre
classe à tapas et à la limite donc on
savait pas trop où est ce qu'on avait
pas sans rattrapage ou pas les usages et
et médiathèque de saint quentin en
yvelines ont pu retrouver leurs lieux de
culture si certaines proposer des
services ont drive le temps du
déconfinement mardi 7 juillet elles ont
rouvert leurs portes et les habitués
étaient au rendez vous exemple à la
verrière toucher les livres les
feuilletés et découvrir les nouveautés
pour faire son stock avant les vacances
c'est de nouveau possible dans les
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines
le site aimé césaire à la verrière est
ouvert les mardis et vendredis de 15h à
18h tout le monde attendait quand même
de pouvoir renouveler le stock qu'ils
ont pu bien utilisé et consulté pendant
à la période de confinement donc on a eu
des appels comme des adhérents ping qui
attendaient avec hâte et dès le premier
jour de réouverture mardi 7 juillet les
adhérents étaient présents heureux de
pouvoir se plonger dans de nouvelles
histoires
j'ai essayé chercher dans les vieux
livres de mes parents mais après c'était
quand même moins bien que de trouver des
livres qui ne correspondaient quoi la
1ère fois je suis venu c'est en mars
2020 mes petits enfants
je leur prends régulièrement des livres
donc il attendait un petit peu fait
dérober le la biotech et regarder
régulièrement sur le site quand est-ce
que ça allait ouvrir pouvoir rentrer
dans la médiathèque
toucher les livres regarder les
nouveautés ça nous manquait beaucoup
quoi naturellement l'espace a été adapté
pour accueillir le public dans de bonnes
conditions sanitaires du gel hydro
alcoolique est à disposition et les
salles de travail et espace bébés ne
sont pas encore accessibles
on ne peut venir quand on veut pour
rendre et emprunter des documents
on peut de nouveau faire des
réservations sur tout le réseau comme on
faisait avant par contre effectivement
il faut porter un masque à partir de 12
ans la médiathèque aimé césaire restera
exceptionnellement ouverte tout l'été
de quoi s'évader même en restant à la
maison et ce week-end débute partir en
livre le rendez vous dédié à la lecture
toute une série d'événements sont à
retrouver à la commanderie vendredi et
samedi
vous pouvez voir le programme sur le
site des médiathèques enfin pour tout
connaître de vos activités estivales du
territoire retrouve un 7,8 loisirs
spécialité en replay sur notre site
internet
le chantier a démarré mercredi fermé
depuis 2012 la déconstruction du silo de
coignières a démarré les travaux
prendront environ deux mois avant de
faire place nette pour la construction
d'un nouveau parking à proximité des
habitations de la résidence des acacias
et du centre commercial coût de la
dépollution 400000 euros
propos recueillis par mathilde et demi
c'est un peu paradoxal un silo qui
contenait au départ 4 174 places de
parking qu'on détruit pour faire à la
place des places de parking voilà donc
on aura une 70 places à peu près de
parking avec un aménagement paysager ce
qui va quand même vraiment transformer
la le quartier ça va errer le quartier
et ensuite en accord avec séquences mais
ça nous verrons en septembre le plan
d'aménagement
il y aura d'autres aménagements dans le
secteur qui seront effectuées il est
arrivé le 1er septembre 2014
six ans après le directeur du golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
passe la main à ses lilas tôt les deux
hommes avaient notamment travaillé
ensemble sur l'organisation de la ryder
cup
ils sont revenus sur cet événement et le
prochain à venir avec michael et demi
d'euros mon plus
beau souvenir c'est ce qu'on a atteint
sur un plan humain c'est clair c'est la
ryder cup était positionné dans comment
dire dans tous les challenges qu'il y
avait évidemment c'était important mais
ça aurait été un désastre si on n'avait
pas eu une équipe à la hauteur et se re
était encore plus désastreux si on
n'avait pas une prestation pour les
clients à la hauteur de ce qu'ils
imaginent d'un site de ryder cup donc
c'est tout ça autour qui est le plus je
dire ouais le plus excitant pour nous la
ryder cup bien sûr on à y participer
de tous les jours
parce que multilingue on était impliqué
dans l'organisation même pendant
l'événement et c'est un rêve mais j'ai
pu visiter presque une dizaine d'autres
ryder cup dans ma vie en angleterre aux
etats unis un peu partout en tant que
fan et je les ai vécus à l'intérieur un
peu comme ça aussi
donc c'est tout autour c'est les deux
années avant surtout l'accélération vers
l'événement et puis les deux années
avant sa de de travailler avec des
personnes qui avaient envie qu'ils
avaient vraiment envie de faire une
réussite de la rédac quelques jeux
olympiques ça va être formidable
c'est vrai que d'organiser cette épreuve
quillan évident on va dire d'un sportif
et les preuves qu'on souhaite à laquelle
on souhaite participer c'est quand même
formidable mais je le placerais aussi
également un peu comme la ryder cup sur
comment on a pu en parler avec paul
ryder cup c'est une étape
voilà et notre notre travail c'est est
de préparer au mieux d'être le plus près
possible pour pour accueillir et faire
en sorte à ce que c'était que cette
étape soit bien vécue par les
collaborateurs soient bien vécu bien des
bilans par le public et les jo je pense
qu'on va l'aborder exactement de la même
façon une étape dans la vie d'ailleurs
le championnat du monde amateur
championnat d'europe jeux olympiques d
open de france sont tout un tas des
tables sur lesquelles il faut qu'on soit
à la hauteur et sur lesquels on doit
mobiliser les équipes et c'est la fin de
cette édition merci de nous avoir suivis
et rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour
le dernier numéro de l'année bon
week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh